not ready
welcome to ASCII Justine I'm a Justine
usually it's a sky Justine but she's not
here she's out she's on a little
sabbatical a little soft back kick cult
Jesse I just seen where you I get well
you're not here paying someone cue the
music
anyone okay great I'll do it who's Nick
everybody's got a question on their mind
okay that's a music system is exactly
left every shout hey guys it's me you
just think I'm here today to take over
the ask Christine show Steve Steve hold
on mace if I go find her I don't want to
be on camera right now though I just
show it to him listen I don't want to
show it to them I posted a vlog for a
reason so that I wouldn't have to
subject them to that here I love if you
want to see it they can go watch it one
no I'm not gonna show it to them
okay but just finish the show don't mess
anything up and I'll see you later
[Music]
everyone is see why do you think that
doing the show um you can click this see
is it common annotation and annotation
right here
[Music]
I'll start these questions okay love you
guys have seen this lot but it's an iPad
is it iPad it is like a mini computer a
mini computer that looks like a book but
it's not a book because it's not book
I'm gonna start off with some legal
questions I don't know if you've heard
about daily move but a website where you
post photos and then people can post
photo comments wait first question is
from Michael Jerry do you like a
cartoons what is that a typo no you know
what
Justine probably doesn't like any
cartoons because all she does is sit and
play that Xbox she plays that Xbox all
day long and let me tell you what I'm
loving to the Xbox I'm into the week I
got that way of wiimotes good like this
doing a little this she doesn't sit
there okay though I'm gonna call of duty
in the Halo just maybe my prestige which
don't care you don't care I Chang glass
wants to know if Justine is a bleak not
one gleek is it sounds like something
dirty it sounds like something nasty
link what is this what is this hand next
question knowing Dixon silly silly silly
bands oh do you like them you know what
I know me speaking from my personal
opinion I do not like them and let me
tell you why because I like circulation
I like the circulation the blood
circulation going through this hand
because I like to type kinda silly bands
I can't think tell you what just mean
brother likes little she would she would
halo awareness Ely bamboo yes kg with
reckons to know how would you decide
which questions to put in your episode
how does she get her questions you know
I just don't know the questions are
always excellent but the answers are not
so excellent do you know why because she
never actually answers the questions
Justine
what is your favorite color and they
just in here my favorite color is I like
cookies what is like do you like the
color of cookies then right now on to
some questions from the book the face
the face of books the books of faces
Facebook would you ever consider coming
to Malta if you know where it is I don't
know
I don't know she probably doesn't know
what Malta is or where it's at probably
google it I heard about Google what's
his new website where you can find
things out you type stuff in and it
tells you things huh good night rarity
color what color would be Karina
obviously she would diet to this
beautiful brunette that I've got going
on here because let me tell you this is
the only hairstyle that anyone should
ever have Jennifer wants to know what
does I just means here it's snack let's
not ever ask her that question one we're
out at dinner this is what it's like to
go to dinner with iJustine oh hey guys
Here I am at dinner and I'm Gideon look
at it's snack just me what are you
eating help tell me what you're eating
just so you put the camera down there's
a time in a place in a place that's not
now I am trying to enjoy my tofu enjoy
the tofu and you're trying to film the
tofu no okay now we're gonna get to some
Twitter questions some tweets we're
gonna take it to the tweets did you see
what I did there it's usually take it to
the streets but I'm gonna take it to the
tweets okay Cameron wants to know if I
Justine is dead because she hasn't
posted any videos
she's taking a sabbatical a sabbatical
and actually she's really not because
she's still vlogging she's still
vlogging on her other iJustine channel
and huh I just jeans iPhone Channel
she didn't post some vlogs and stuff
like crazy she'd be putting that eye out
there I was creepy man we late never
blah blah blah blah blah Jack this one's
no there was a zombie apocalypse which
just means to Blanc yeah she would I
mean we're out of dinner and she's
vlogging my tofu I mean it can it get
any more boring alright you know what
I think that's all the questions I have
for you guys today if you think that I
seem a little bit angry it is because
I'm not one to be in front of the camera
okay
I like to sit behind my computer I don't
like to leave I don't to go outside
I just like to type cuz I got all my
friends there got all my friends there
only internet don't lots to go anywhere
I will leave you with this piece of
wisdom actually I'm not gonna leave you
with anything except oh maybe you should
subscribe that was one thing that she
you say there may be other things that
I'm missing um yeah okay I will see you
guys sometime probably never again
because
[Music]